mon avis dès aujourd'hui guy bedos et je
serais tenté de dire qu'il s'agit là
d'un cru 80 alors le beau gosse 80 80
est il sensible au vent des événements à
la couleur du toa à la fièvre des hommes
g j'ai le sentiment qu'il a changé oh
oui oui c'est le changement dans la
continuité comme disent certains hommes
politiques que nous connaissons je crois
pas non plus me renier jeu j'évolue
j'évolue mais c'est vrai que je ne me
sens pas non plus isolé de ce qui se
passe j'ai les yeux ouverts les oreilles
ouvertes aux 6es et j'attrape tout ce
qui se passait et en dehors de ma vie à
moi aussi j'aimerais en être une espèce
de d'éponger je me nourris de tout ça il
veut dose vous n'avez jamais vous n'avez
jamais été très tendre pour les hommes
politiques mais j'ai l'impression que
vous les aimez de moins en moins austère
que je ne sais pas eu personnellement je
veux dire que
j'ai pas de rancune personnelle contre
quiconque
enfin si peut-être un un peu j'ai mes
préférences dans la dans l'hostilité si
on peut dire mais
c'est la fonction politique est devenue
terriblement décevante mais je l'âge est
important un enfant c'est une porte
ouverte
c'est dans tous les journaux c'est
partout oui mais vous êtes moins
militant qu'autrefois cette fois si vous
ne voulez être sûr le théâtre sur la
scène du théâtre qu'un artiste
oui il tend des partis pris et peut-être
même des certitudes
c'est vrai c'est vrai que je ne suis
plus sûr de rien je suis comme je ne
sais plus qui plus sûr de mes dégoût que
de mes goûts
je ne peux réagir que qu'au coup par
coup il ya des choses qui continua à me
tenir éveillé c'est tout ce qui me
révolte c'est la justice c'est sage de
ça je vais toujours sûr et ça fonctionne
toujours ça d'où qu'elles viennent
mais
je ne me sens pas aussi compagnon de
route entre guillemets de certaines
organisations politiques l'époque et
puis cette fois-ci vous souhaitez
relever un défi celui de faire rire avec
des thèmes de plus en plus angoissant et
là il ya comme une ambiguïté parce que
je lirai que vous êtes de plus en plus
heureux oui oui oui mais
et je ne sais pas comment font les gens
pour être heureux sans sans aucune ombre
à leur bonheur est ce que ça existe je
sais pas je rencontre des gens ce qu'ils
ont l'air mais ils ont l'air tellement
battre que qu'évidemment je peux
peut-être que peut-être que ça me sera
refusé c'est pas très bonne est ce que
je dis là mais c'est vrai je je ne peux
pas être malheureux d'une façon
complaisante non plus c'est vrai je suis
bien obligé d'avouer que ça va pour moi
tu as un métier que j'aime qui continue
à me réussir malgré tout toutes les
embûches tout ce qui qui pourrait me
coûter cher
et puis et puis dans ma vie ça là aussi
alors radoteur ou guignols des temps
modernes vous radotez moi je veux dire
par rapport à tout ce que vous venez le
dirigeant cède 6,6 et pour m'insulter
moi et fait venir aura d'auteur autre
vie mais là on a commencé dans la
courtoisie et vous me connaissez je vais
me réveiller
après si je dois dire que sur scène vous
avez toujours rêvé y était et vous
frapper de plus en plus oui oui mais
justement vous savez
dans la vie
je surprends quelquefois et je déçois et
l'a peut-être que dans cette émission
il ya la différence à la radio
avec le grand échiquier par un bon on
s'est rencontrés à la télévision qui est
plus grand défi qui est un spectacle
la différence entre ce livre que je
viens de publier
et qui nous réunit je crois et et le
spectacle se dire que il ya une sorte
d'intimité alors là c'est pas je crois
pas que je me trahissent en tant qu'être
humain quand je suis sur scène mais il y
a il ya le ferrailleur qui est sur scène
et puis dans la vie je suis démaquiller
moi je suis pas prisonnier d'un
personnage vous savez alors pour parler
clair ou ou forcés souvent être méchant
parce que c'est votre rôle est parce que
vous avez des choses à dire mais sa
reliure est affreusement les gens quand
ils sont venus s'asseoir dans une salle
pour rire et pour rire des travers de
l'époque est bon et on l'est on les
connaît plus ou moins tous tout le monde
sait tout finalement tout le monde est
capable d'une certaine manière de dire
tout ce que je dis tout ce que disent
mes copains mes collègues mes petits
camarades y compris celui qui se
présente à la présidence de la
république pour que vous ne vous
présentez pas connu se présente je dois
dire que là et il va vers une publicité
tout à fait évidente oui a besoin de
tout cela dit les choses d'ailleurs
clairement non plus souvent d'accord que
lui chez moi j'ai le même j'ai à peu
près le même avis que lui sur certaines
choses et sur certains certaines
personnes mais
je crois qu'il fait du tort profession
en allant se commettre avec les hommes
politiques mais contrairement à jean
daniel qui finit son édito de ce matin
en disant qu'il refuse de choisir entre
les impuissants et les bouffons
je trouve que il ya une certaine
noblesse être bouffon et et
je vois je trouve que c'est mieux d'être
molière que depuis 14 c'est mieux d'être
chaplin que truman si vous voyez ce que
je veux dire
alors pour vous guy bedos il y aller les
blues enchaînements du printemps il y à
celui de 1979 il y à celui de 1980 et
pour moi et pour vous surtout c'est un
printemps qui a tjrs à un an et cet âge
là c'est celui de votre fils nicolas je
crois que tout pourrait commencer par là
et même lorsque je regarde la couverture
de sol y aura n'attendant la bombe qui
vient après l'autre livre qui avait pour
titre je craque
il ya toute la différence qu'il peut y
avoir entre la désespérance et
l'insignifiance cette fois ci je crois
la voie royale pour être pour vous le
bonheur
wisair que j'ai pris le risque d'être
insignifiant puisque je pars de c'est un
journal ce livre sa faillite pourrait
être un livre d'ailleurs
et là je le dis sans coquetterie je
n'étais pas du tout sûr que ce sera un
livre j'écris un moment que pau pour se
faire livrer il faut il faut avoir le
courage de passer pour un con je rajoute
d'ailleurs que deux héros entassés chez
les libraires mais bon tant mieux s'ils
sont assez pour vous vous n'allez pas
les chasser alors mais bon
j'étais pas sûr du tout que ce serait
intéressant ma façon de couver mon petit
dernier mais en fait cet enfant qui me
comble que j'aime
et que j'ai attendu que j'ai accompagné
pendant un nom c'est en même temps un
prétexte il faut que ce soit clair j'ai
pas voulu simplement jouer les papas
poules pour reprendre le titre d'un
feuilleton télévisé que je n'ai pas vu
d'ailleurs mais dont on parle beaucoup
parce que je me doute bien que mes
histoires de mômes
ça pourrait être nés en union et et sans
intérêt pour les autres rien à voir avec
papa poule
moi j'ai pas vu j'ai pas vu ça je parle
d'autre chose
en fait je parle de ce gosse mais ce
gosse c'est là c'est l'enfant du monde
si l'on peut dire c'est c'est le nouveau
monde c'est d'une certaine manière c'est
d'abord c'est pour lui que j'ai écrit
c'est un je trouve qu'on doit on doit
écrire ses oeuvres posthumes et non
seulement les éclaire bien sûr mais les
publié de son vivant comme ça on voit
l'effet que ça fait
et bon mais c'est pour nicolas
pour nicolas et par extension pour
mélanie pour pour les autres enfants que
j'ai dans dans longtemps il aura lui 20
ans en l'an 2000 et c'est vrai que
c'était une façon de lui demander pardon
quoi demander pardon de le faire venir
parmi nous à cette époque là pour la
coupe pour l'apocalypse comme vous dites
cd rom ou craignez pour demain mais si
vous avez d'autres enfants on pourrait
dire aussi que c'est la première fois
que vous êtes papa je comprends pas la
question c'est la première fois que vous
prenez pour un père ah oui
je me sens tellement peur des finances
si vous avez fait répéter deux fois
c'est vrai que si si mais aux enfants
écoutent comprendrait pas que seront
alors non c'est à dire que c'est la
première fois que je vis ma paternité
dans cette espèce de d'harmonie quoi
voilà c'est vrai c'est la première fois
alors j'ai fait une comparaison je ne
sais pas si vous allez à trouver
flatteuse entre ce livre en attendant la
bombe
et puis le livre de françois mitterrand
ici et maintenant et je crois vous
auriez pu le prendre ce titre ici et
maintenant l'enjeu dire par là que vous
traitez pas le g8 et le sujet tout à
fait différent mais que tous les deux
vous êtes passé par l'écriture alors je
me suis demandé si françois mitterrand
était fait pour aller jusqu'au bout de
sa politique et si vous étiez fait pour
aller jusqu'au bout de votre reer
alors qu'il y as peut-être justement un
bonheur d'écriture qu'il faudrait n'ont
pas épuisé
mais peut-être caresser d'un peu plus
près du tiers en fait vous demander à
mitterrand de ne pas se présenter aux
élections et à moi d'arrêter de dont je
reconnais un pouvoir d'écriture
en tout cas c'est vrai que du point de
vue de l'écriture j'ai lu démocratie
française et j'ai lu l'autre livre de
mitterrand je parle pas du dernier j'ai
un trou c'est plus le titre la paille et
le grain l'aja pas la paille et le grain
c'est vrai que si on devait élire le
président de république sur son style il
faudrait voter mitterrand
vous pensez que le rire peut encore
passer par la dérision et vous êtes
interrogez vous sur votre reer vous fait
tellement d'années lisent sur ce que
vous faites pour on peut se demander si
sur scène non mais c'est pablo
cordonnerie sur scène sur scène roulant
ça vient ça devient un charnelle il y a
des gens en face et je me dis que c'est
pas naturel qui soit là parce qu'il ya
des programmes de télé aussi mauvais
qu'ils soient c'est entend dresser
devant sa télé donc
je prends pas ça surtout lorsque vous
passez qui se dérangent au moins pour ça
enfin non très franchement je pourrais
très bien faire un numéro de claquettes
là-dessus horizons mais c'est le
meilleur je pense un peu d'air du rire
mais meilleur que de veau aux meilleurs
que villeray meilleur que coluche très
franchement je pense que tous ces gens
là ont du talent
mais si je vous disais que je préfère ce
qu'ils font à ce que je fais je serai
pas sincère oui vous ne feriez plus
alors oui j'arrêterai net et je ferai
mes adieux moi aussi non j'aime beaucoup
faire mon métier j'ai une espèce de de
goût de good amitié aussi pour les gens
qui sont là parce que encore une fois je
crois pas que ce soit du ca
c'est émouvant moi je trouve des gens
qui viennent qui sortent de chez eux
toutes les difficultés que cela comporte
qui viennent payer une place je ne crois
pas que ça soit un dut encore une fois
et ça me touche quand je vois des gens
qui qui qui reste là
alors que je les insulte souvent que je
leur dis des choses très agréables
le public a fait des progrès je trouve
que le les gens n'ont pas fait de
progrès mais mais
mais le public dans une salle je trouve
qu'il encaisse très très bien le public
vous êtes acquis d'une manière générale
non pas vraiment vous savez déjà été
sifflés vous avez déjà été rejetée vous
avez été déjà mise à la porte je n'ai
jamais l'islam
non non ça non s'il ya très très très
très longtemps c'était dans mon pays
c'était en algérie c'était c'était
c'était peut-être première fois que je
passais sur une grande scène
ces démissions de mon oncle jacques
bedos qui faisait illusion télévision là
bas et c'est dans ma ville alger la
ville où je suis né que des troufions de
l'époque et le public là bas ont pris au
premier degré ce qui était déjà au
second
c'était un sketch que je faisais à à
saint germain des prés avec un certain
succès dans un un cabaret de l'époque où
se produisaient d'ailleurs devos jean
yanne jacques dufilho enfin j'étais en
bonne compagnie et ça faisait hurler de
rire saint germain des prés mai à alger
ça n'a pas pris et là ils m'ont sorti de
nos émouvant sortie mais si je suis
sorti parce qu'il comprend mais
mais sinon non non il ya des soirs où
c'est plus dur parce que je me mets un
difficulté je les excitants les gens je
leur dis des choses et puis je je je
fais quelquefois de l'opportunisme à
l'envers comme évidemment la politique y
compris la politique politicienne et
quelquefois pour pour la fustiger à ma
manière
bon la politique a une place importante
dans mon spectacle dans ce que j'appelle
mes improvisations qui sont pas toujours
les improvisations et des improvisations
très réglée contrôler
évidemment je prends le risque de
déplaire à tout le monde depuis quelques
temps oui mais attention prendre le
risque de déplaire peut-être à
quelques-uns pour plaire à tout le monde
aussi écouté par là aussi si j'en juge
par la liste de fréquentation des alsh
de produits bah oui ça va mais qui
veulent oser dit tout à l'heure le
premier degré c'est vrai que parfois il
est dangereux de présenter un sketch qui
peut ne pas être compris je me rappelle
ma raquette où je me souviens également
de cette pièce à la comédie française de
grand-mère rixe ou vraiment les choses
au 1er mai grèce oui très très belles
pièces mais véritablement aujourd'hui on
ne peut pas la présenter en présenter du
moins extrait sans faire un préambule
oui parce que c'est vrai que sur
certains thèmes le racisme notamment et
tous les racismes que ce soit racine de
pau racisme deux catégories de sexe
aussi appelé les choses les
plaisanteries sur les femmes et à mon
genre fait beaucoup et je suis pas la
nuit des femmes j'ai pas l'impression
que ce soit le type le plus misogyne le
plus phallocrate comme on dit que j'ai
rencontrés mais il m'arrive
oui d'avoir à à donner le mode d'emploi
quelquefois après à certaines
spectatrices qui viennent me voir nos
bons mais ça c'est risques du métier
mais est il vrai que aujourd'hui de plus
en plus les comics se méfie d'eux mêmes
parfois ils auraient même honte de
provoquer le rire ah non j'ai pas honte
moi j'aime bien quand les gens en vie
j'aime bien parce qu'il y est c'est là
aussi j'ai le temps où le moment même où
ça arrive
j'ai même quand j'ai l'air
d'un énergumène sur scène mais c'est un
jeu vous savez je suis très joueurs
j'aime jouer moi ou alors je me fâche
alors là c'est clair que tant que je
taquine c'est que au fond j'aime bien y
compris dans la lucidité c'est à dire
que je bon un exemple au hasard vous je
vous cherche des cross quelquefois dans
le livre non mais j'aime la manière dont
vous en parler mais si si vous détestez
je serai pas là je signe à moi j'ai des
gens avec qui je fais pas d'émissions de
radio je fais pas une émission de télé
et ça vient pas d'où ça vient de moi
comme quoi il ya des jours où la vie a
du talent comme vous les temps où les
gens peuvent avoir du talent ou du moins
de la générosité et dès lors les
beaucoup des jo dans le public
yahiaoui il ya cette espèce de de
réaction enfantine
moi j'aime bien quand les gens sont
comme des mômes dans une salle qui sont
surpris qu'ils font des eau qui font des
actions choc et même par certaines
choses parce que là tout d'un coup on
est en train entre entre gosse quoi
parce que moi aussi je là sur scène je
je m'amuse comme un mot alors justement
dans un attendant la bombe vous dit très
clairement parce que lorsqu'on écrit on
contrôle quand même ces mots parce que
lorsqu'on dit surtout dans une
conversation peut aller un peu plus loin
on peut se laisser dépasser par les
phrases est le même mais là vous écrivez
je suis très bavard mais j'ai pour règle
de ne jamais attaquer quelqu'un en
public sur ces actes privé et pourtant
généralement quand je parle ce n'est pas
de la diffamation
c'est de l'information vous estimez que
c'est vrai ça oui oui oui c'est vrai
c'est vrai en tout cas c'est une
information peut être un peu brutal mais
qui fait pendant à la désinformation
dont nous sommes quelquefois victimes y
compris sur sur les ondes eux qui nous
reçoivent aujourd'hui il ya une
politesse qui frise la flyer de riches
et certains de vos confrères
journalistes car je crois que c est
ainsi que vous vous le mets
qui moi me désole parce que
c'est très mauvais ça c'est très mauvais
parce que les gens sentent qu'on leur
ment ils savent des choses qui se savent
ils font parler puis faut reparler
nettement jeu puisque vous me citez je
parle de certains de vos confrères en
disant je crois un moment à croire
qu'ils ont appris leur métier l'école
hôtelière il pose la question comment on
passe des plats oui mais alors les
sièges antivieillissement vous estimez
comme ce qu'on a des amis il faut être
impertinent à leur endroit il faut ne
pas être courtois mais dans le même
temps je crois que vous allez recevoir
la mode est votre pièce car vous avez
écrit un livre qui est très beau mais
certains ne vont pas vouloir l'écrire
parce que justement par rapport à vous
ils ne veulent pas entrer dans un jeu
contraire donc ils ne diront pas que
c'est bien ils iront me trouveront même
tous les défauts pour en parler vous
l'avez déjà éprouvée je suis persuadé
que des gens qui n'écrivent pas sur vous
sur votre livre jeudi ou alors dans
minute on écrit des ans mais il faut les
accepter aussi les aurores lorsque vous
avez été vous aussi à leur place mais
c'est vrai que les choses restent quoi
qu'on fasse il arrive un moment où les
jeux sont faits
je crois pas que je puisse me gagné
tellement de nouveaux amis vous savez
quoi que je fasse
j'écris vous avez nécessité pour tôt
parce que je suis assez content de ce
que je me suis fait tout de même je les
laisse entrer présent alors c'est vrai
que
pour un livre comme celui que je publie
là il ya plusieurs handicaps d'or je
suis connu ailleurs et d'autres que moi
ont souffert un petit peu de cette sorte
de notoriété oui je pense à simone à
simone signoret un moment qui a dû
écrire un deuxième livre pour prouver
qu'elle avait bien écrit le premier je
trouve ça quand même extraordinaire non
parce que désolé on a on accapare les
trois minutes avec simone signoret pour
s'apercevoir qu'elle qu'elle est très
bonne dans son propre texte aussi
qu'elle n'a pas besoin d'aidés
dialoguiste bon et des auteurs moi je
crois pas la hiérarchie des genres
je crois rêver c'est vrai que je suis
très agacé mais comme ça deux secondes
quand on me dit mais alors vous vous
écrivez vous aussi alors vous vous y
mettez aussi et qu'est ce que je fais
d'autres écrire un sketch
moi je vis de ma plume depuis 20 ans
devos écrit j'écris collu j'écris tous
les gens qui font ce métier c'est pas
parce qu'on est capable en plus
d'interpréter ce qu'on joue qu'on
n'écrit pas bon c'est un genre très très
délicat vous savez le rire le sketch
beaucoup de romancier confirmé d'auteurs
de théâtre confirmer s'ils sont essayés
je veux pas dire de nom la bâche pour
rideau d'embêter gens mais ici sans
casser les reins c'est très c'est très
difficile de faire cours et puis lorsque
vous êtes sur scène vous écrivez une
deuxième fois car au vous avez écrit
même une première fois où quelqu'un a
écrit pour nous dire ce que vous êtes
sur scène vous dit vous êtes seul essai
le trajet itinéraire ce que jean loup
dabadie mon oncle pas mon ami et
et mon co auteur aussi puisqu'il il ya
certains sketchs qui sont écrits par lui
depuis toujours en somme depuis le début
là je ne suis qu'un acteur en somme qui
interprète le texte d'un auteur comme un
acteur acteurs de théâtre il avait assez
bien dit ça je crois dans votre émission
aujourd'hui qu'hier soir il avait dit
que j'étais passée de la troisième
personne à la première personne
je le fais encore parce que j'en éprouve
le besoin
j'ai besoin de parler aux gens
d'abord ça me rend dire gg un trop-plein
vous savez dans la vie je ne suis pas
tout à fait pareil je ne dis pas tout
alors sur scène et dont je suis sûr que
compte pas m'interrompre sur scène bah
tu sais ça peut m'arriver
mais bon j'ai la parole alors je
l'apprends et j'ai besoin de dire ces
choses-là aux gens et peut-être aussi
dans un
un esprit de journalistes et c'est pour
ça aussi que je fais un bouquin qui est
un journal au fond je suis un
journaliste un journaliste frustré je je
devrais pas avoir à faire ça mais j'en
éprouve le besoin parce que c'est une
autre relation avec avec les gens et
puis guy bedos vous êtes et frileux est
fragile et vous essayez de sur scène
peut-être l'envié que je suis folle de
tous vous êtes très fragile et vous êtes
facilement blessés et ont peut-être vous
comprendre dans les petites dans les
seuls titres des sketches que vous
présentez gens regardent quelques-uns la
[ __ ] de gosse manque de tendresse
envie de crier l'amour fou alors tout de
suite je pense à ces nouveaux nouveau
vsat et des nouveaux nouveau et tout de
suite je pense à un épisode de votre vie
une parenthèse que nous ouvrons nous
allons refaire mais très vite c'est
celle de sophie daumier vous en parlez
dans votre livre je dois dire que vous
avez fait un long trajet avec elle
c'était un tandem je dire que je vous
attendais
furieux je vous trouve délicat joue trop
plutôt peiné touché blessés à vif
plutôt indifférent que mes prisons et
vous dites d'ailleurs ceci est très
significatif reçu le livre de sophie qui
vient de paraître en librairie
je l' ai parcouru plus que lui
véritablement c'est d'une telle
médiocrité de fond et de forme que près
de ce qu'elle écrit les articles de
minutes où d'ici paris semble avoir été
signé par sartre dans les temps modernes
alors quand il lance était très vive au
départ mais c'est tout laurel et hardy
des choses plus est plus nuancé oui de
loin cramponner à mon rocher j'assiste
pétrifiés à la noyade
cela ses plus tendres mais c'est plus
tragique car vous avez vous donné du
moins l'impression de dire que sans vous
elle ne peut plus rien mais on referme
la parenthèse si vous préférez ne pas
trop parler
oui bon je veux pas aller beaucoup plus
loin que que ce que j'ai écrit le fait
est que c'est un journal c'est un
journal écrit au jour le jour et qu'au
moment où j'écrivais ce journal le livre
que ce fui a publié bon et qui m'était
destinée c'était une espèce de l'être
très violente qui m'étaient adressés bon
bah je les ai reçus en pleine poire et
il ya eu toute une après un film de
woody allen
où le personnage principal dans
manhattan est un étagement un humoriste
la télévision j'étais très très très
étonné par le thème de ce film la
comparaison s'arrête là mais qui est lui
qui a une femme houcine des ex femme qui
publie un livre et qui lui apprend juste
après qu'elle va même en faire un film
dieu merci ça ne sera épargné ça je
crois vous dites quand même les vrais
mots parce qu'elle vous a traité de
tyran domestique d'arnaqueurs
d'imposteurs d'opportunistes ai-je l'air
que là vous avez eu mal et c'est tout de
suite après que vous êtes très violent
avec elle je ne dirai pas ce que vous
dites
car s'il s'est dit dans le livre et je
crois que je peux le dire si j'ai dit
puisque je l'écris je peux le dire sans
il s'appelait parle à mon coeur ma tête
est malade et j'ai dit j'ai beaucoup
parlé à son coeur mais sa tête était
très malade
fermez la parenthèse dollars pour de bon
alors là vous êtes également très vives
et tout ce que vous rencontrez je veux
dire très agressive mais d'une
agressivité qui parfois vous révoltez
vous même parce que dans le fond vous ne
voudriez pas être cet homme là aussi
méchant ce que vous dites par exemple
sur sylvie vartan le playback terre que
lassé de la pertinence mais la
pertinence parfois va beaucoup plus loin
que la diffamation il n'y a pas de
diffamation
je crois pas non je bomba de dire que
bah oui ça rejoint complètement quand je
dis que si lui entend chante une partie
de son tour de chant en playback c'est
pas la tueuse source de l'information
c'est la vérité est ce qu'elle peut dire
le contraire je les ai vus et je suis je
vous jure que je peux aller demi de
civils en tant que je trouve très
mignonne et dont je comprends le succès
vraiment alors vous êtes choisi trois
grands pères enfin renoir prévert arago
en fait vous êtes choisi trois grands
pères que vous n'avez pas et vous êtes
passé à côté d'eux parce que vous avez
fréquenté un tout autre mandat lors des
toutes les raisons peut-être d'être
déçus
renoir et prévert c'est des gens qui ont
fait partie de ma vie
plus profondément aragon aragon c'est
toujours c'est le sait le sait le genre
même du journal qui me vaut la rencontre
d'aragon il se trouve que justement j'ai
rencontré aragon parce que il m'a invité
à déjeuner il m'a fait il a su que
j'étais à marseille lui était à toulon
et il a rencontré mais c'est vrai que
j'ai écrit sur aragon et sur la sur la
vieillesse d'un homme quel qu'il soit on
peut de tout pensé d'aragon moi même je
pense des choses aragon qui sont peuplés
tellement agréable
mais s'est fait l'auteur de deux romans
de pour m
admirable et c'est vrai que là le
crépuscule gens de cette sorte le
toucher terriblement
et puis vous plaisait dans cette
compagnie les gens de votre âge ne
seront peut-être pas de ventre
environnement car un certain moment vous
écrire je dois être atteinte de
gérontophilie chronique car de
rubinstein à jouhandeau en passant par
maurice genevoix je raffole de ces
éblouissant vieillards des arts et des
lettres qui n'ayant plus rien à prouver
plus rien à vendre dans la plénitude
d'un talent depuis longtemps reconnu
accède à la divine évidence des enfants
d'abord c'est beau par rapport à un âge
reconnu et ses boues par rapport à
l'écriture donc je serais tenté de
croire que parfois vous plaisait aussi
riche en effet les halles faites
attention parce que je crois je vais
vous remplacer au grand échiquier ça je
suis à lui atteint du syndrome chancel
vieillard j'ai également la même
tendresse pour eux c'est grâce à vous
que j'ai connu je ne vois par exemple
j'ai revu les missions bah je regrette
pas du tout de la barre en cours est
stable et il me plaisait bien y avait
beau être de l'académie française il
avait une insolence il avait
et puis tous les gens dont je parle
certains vous connaissez très bien mieux
que moi un type comme albert cohen est
un type qui me fascine aussi parce que
c'est vrai que moi j'aime beaucoup les
enfants et c'est vrai que les grands
peintres les grands écrivains
peut-être parce que justement l'iso
cette espèce de naïveté qui vient d'un
travail solitaire etc
il me touche justement parce que ils ont
des idées ingénuité qui me ramène à mon
fils quoi et quelle différence faites
vous entre le premier livre je craque et
celui ci en attendant la boum à qui vous
le devez d'abord à l'enfant oui à une
autre vie une autre femme
une autre femme et c'est le commencement
d'un autre parcours oui c2c de crise il
y en a un qui a été qui a été écrit et
sous l'emprise du cafard du mal-être et
là c'est une crise aiguë de bonheur à un
moment où vraiment
ça ne se fait pas quoi j'ai trouvé ça
pas convenable naître heureux à ce point
à ce moment là et j'ai eu besoin de
fixer aussi les images de bonheur parce
que parce que c'est provisoire mais vous
vous adressez à votre femme et vous
dites n'est pas peur joue je ne me
tuerait pas cette semaine je voulais je
voulais seulement dire que l'idée du
suicide
je les jeux les oui c'est vrai donc vous
dites je laisse cette idée du suicide
je la porte en moi depuis l'enfance je
vis avec très bien c'est même pour moi
l'ultime expression de la liberté de
savoir que je peux choisir ma mort ça
m'aide à vivre même dans le bonheur vous
dites ça même même en rigolant comme
vous dites bluff sincérité oui des
mêlées à la wii
j'écris ça toujours parce que c'est un
journal très très touché très perturbée
par le suicide de jean seberg que
j'avais appris la veille
et puis
et puis par le suicide aussi de jean
louis borie que j'aimais beaucoup
bon j'ai appris ces suicides là au
moment où j'écris vrai alors c'est
peut-être l'intérêt de ce genre là qui
qui qui est classique enfin le journal
ça ça se fait depuis longtemps
en littérature
c'est que c'est vraiment de l'écriture
spontanée quoi je ne choisis pas mes
thèmes c'est eux qui me choisisse est
alors bon il se trouve que j'ai parlé du
suicide parce que c'est vrai que je je
déteste je déteste comme beaucoup de
gens
le la maladie et tout ce que tout ce qui
est score qu'elle m'a dit j'ai pas envie
de faire très bon là dessus d'ailleurs
parce que parce que alors là permettez
moi de vous le dire ou de le dire bon
vous avez perdu notre cher aujourd'hui
tout à l'heure la femme de jacques bedos
qui était plus que votre nom par dit
pardonnez moi de vous le dire ce sera
dit pas son nom je vous je vais vous en
délivrer oui c'est sûr que j'y pense et
gens j'aime tant
[Musique]
j'ai ouï gcc c'est effectivement là
comment dire le piège de ce genre là le
journal c'est que c'est qu'il ya des
personnages qu'on manque on perd en
route quoi moi et karine la femme de
jacques et dans ce livre là et il ya des
images d'elle dans ce livre là parce que
c'est aussi une espèce d'albums l'album
de soleil et mer aujourd'hui il faisait
- pourquoi il veut dire je le crée nous
et est mince entre le cri est il si lens
entre le père fils est ce qu'on peut
appeler le comportement courtois mais on
a quand même l'impression que vous avez
changé de cap et je crois que tout ce
que vous avez dit tendrait à nous le
faire croire vous êtes plus attentifs
vous êtes moins égoïste je ne veux pas
dire moins sûr mais vous êtes différents
jurys
ce n'est pas seulement vis c'est
peut-être peut-être vous avez compris un
peu plus tard je suis sans doute rassuré
sur mon sort
vous savez dans ces métiers là on se
bagarre beaucoup on se bagarre on a peur
on a peur on a toujours peur et il
arrive à nous
bon on commence à tout de même avoir des
repères on sait qu'on
qui a pas de raison que tout d'un coup
ça n'aille plus du tout et qu'on n'ait
plus le droit à la parole quoi c'est
très important
d'avoir ça et je suis peut-être rassuré
là dessus alors ça me permet tout de
même d'être de plus en plus attentif aux
autres et de moins en moins dirigées
vers mon nombril
même quand j'ai écrit un journal intime
une faible estime oui nous sommes là
l'un en face de l'autre il ya le
personnage que l'on connaît qui est sur
scène qui forcément cris dit des choses
dures juge parfois et puis il ya l'autre
qui dans la vie et qui est tout à fait
différent de celui là et les gens ne
font jamais la différence d'abord
doivent qu'il l'a fait à cette théorie
n'ont pas le temps les pauvres vous
ainsi si vraiment il devait aller au
delà et souvent jacques au fond c'est
une
c'est une politesse qu'on leur doit
quand on est un personnage public cessé
de donner quelques quelques informations
supplémentaires supplément d'information
à la fois sur soi même plus c'est vrai
que bon on a tendance à se regarder dans
une glace
enfin moi quand je me regarde dans une
glace il ya du monde autour quoi alors
bon c'est vrai que cette paternité
l'anti beaucoup question tout au long de
ce journal est
il ya quelques années j'en parle à un
type tu m'avais dit très gentiment alors
que j'avais déjà une fille leslie qui
est maintenant une de vos concerts qui
travaillent ici pas besoin assez
brillamment d'ailleurs vous avez une
filière très fier très fier très mal et
il m'avait dit quand on vous voit faire
le comique à la télé on n'imagine pas
que vous pouvez avoir des enfants c'est
quand même fantastique quoi ça sert que
le type me réduisait à cette fonction de
guignol et c'est pas ces mesures hâtives
mais il me niait toute humanité
c'est c'est énorme non d'ailleurs
lorsque vous vous attaquez comme vous le
faites
on ne peut pas croire que vous êtes
tendre dans le même temps d'autres
pouvez vous le dire cela et c'est
peut-être que vous avez voulu prouver un
écrit rang cette fois ci c'est à dire m
c'est une certaine manière les choses à
leur place d'ailleurs la vérité la
vérité n'est pas celle que vous
attendiez un certain moment et je le
disais au commencement de cette
conversation
vous étiez plutôt partisan et parce que
vous citez sincère vous était sincère
mais parce que c'est sincère vous ne
voulez plus être dupes alors on va
parler de trahison
vous avez abandonné en route beaucoup
beaucoup de vos compagnes au alors ses
deux jumeaux abandonnés non alors alors
là je laisserai pas passer ça vous
parler aux autres des tanks de la
fraternité du socialisme oui
effectivement il s'est passé plein de
choses et puis vous êtes soit clair
c'est très important en ce moment je me
suis je dit pas je quitte pas le navire
un du tout c'est le navire qui
s'éloignent un peu parce qu'elle là où
le bon j'y peux rien tu es là mois puis
je regarde ce qui se passe je suis un
citoyen ordinaire pour ça en tout cas vu
comme comme tout le monde quoi et c'est
vrai que
à un moment j'ai cru que la gauche
française allait faire des choses et je
trouvais ça très sain s'était pas je
souhaitais pas la mort des autres je
faisais pas partie des gens qui
préparaient des charrettes et des gibets
comme certains j'avais rien à gagner
dans cette histoire mais j'ai cru que
c'était c'était bien je crois réellement
au pluralisme et à l'alternance
bon il se révèle que que ces gens là se
la gauche des chefs parce qu'il faut pas
confondre il faut pas tout mélanger il
ya ya des atouts tous les gens autour
tout et milliers millions de gens qui
aimeraient bien que ça change pour eux
et qu'ils y croient et
et qui n'ont pas qu'ils n'ont pas
l'espoir ça change si ça change pas je
te vends et qui sont déçus tout autant
que moi je dis un moment je crois les
jeux c'est vrai quelqu'un de mon
entourage avait vu tracées à la bombe
écarlate
une phrase très très post soixante
huitard de la gauche
exactement je ne sais plus la gauche
un espoir qui sent la mort bon c'est pas
franchement agréable décrire ça et je
rajoute certains parmi mes mes relations
d'état major du ps du pc m'en voudront
sans doute je me suis tu te résine
exactement je m'en fous en faisant
d'avoir publié ça
il me traiteront d'irresponsables en
effet c'est ce qui nous sépare
eux ils sont responsables ça ne pas être
exactement ça c'est mieux que ça j'écris
mieux que je ne la crois lorsque vous
présentez votre spectacle
lorsque vous dites que vous avez dire
vous égratignez vous égratignez tout le
monde est par exemple d'égratigner
georges marchais et vous le faites
souvent devant les communistes et les
communistes applaudissent quel est votre
sentiment devant ce style
applaudissements c'est parce qu'ils ont
compris parce qu'ils savent que c'est
que jauzion degré ou parce que contraire
c'est au premier deux ans je fais je
fais pas campagne contre le marché il
faut bien dire que mes coups les plus
durs sont plutôt contre lescar
parce que jusqu'à preuve contraire c'est
pas marcher d'être au pouvoir en ce
moment donc
je crois que si on devait compter les
coups j'en donne plus à droite qu'à
gauche
quand même mais mais c'est une question
de loyauté et me trouvant devant un
public favorable à marcher par
excellence puisque je suis tu es sur son
terrain mon opportunisme à moi c'est
justement de dire des choses qui sont
pas fatalement un agréable a des
oreilles de militants communistes
oui et alors là ils rigolent ils
applaudissent souvent mais ça veut pas
dire qu'ils vont voter autrement et
d'ailleurs je ne cherche pas à les
empêcher de voter marché ce sont ce que
je disais pour les les hommes publics
moi comme vous par exemple les jeux sont
faits un certain moment vous savez on a
on a nos voix les voix je ne crois pas
beaucoup aux miracles des débats qui
vont tout changer qui vont tout faire
basculer
quoi qu'on fasse on à sa clientèle mais
guy lauzon
vous avez fait la preuve à l'instant de
la différence qu'il peut y avoir entre
la chose écrite et la chose parlez vous
avez donné un texte qui êtes vous je
dois dire que vous ne vous êtes pas trop
trompé par rapport aux responsables mais
comme j'aime bien que l'on soit exact
dans ce genre de circonstances je vais
vous dire ce que vous avez écrit à ce
sujet pour que vous ne soyez pas
défavorisés parce que par rapport à ce
que vous venez de dire non grenouillage
voilà donc en attendant la banque voilà
ce que vous dites
certains parmi mes relations d'état
major du ps ou du pc seront sans doute
si le molise d'un jour ulcérée de ce que
j'écris ou reproduits et vous me
traiterait d'irresponsable et je vous
répondrai qu'en effet c'est ce qui nous
sépare
vous vous êtes responsable blague était
à peu près mais enfin je reste un jeu de
mots quoi vous avez quoi qu'il arrive
envie de changer la vie de changer de
musique la vie changer de couleur l'ami
de changer de thor lhenry de partir et
peut-être pour arriver alors je me
demande si vous êtes bien dans votre
univers cette fois si vous ne voulez
plus faire peu votre métier mais c'est
vraiment un métier
lorsqu on le pousse à ce point et qu'on
entre aussi fort dans l'événement j'en
doute
cette fois je suis tout le temps où
j'étais persuadé que
j'allais tout changer c'est vrai vous le
croyez plus non non non non non je je je
pense que
[Musique]
c'est beaucoup plus long que ça et puis
ça nous échappe à nous ça échappe à tout
le monde
encore une fois je crois pas que coluche
et et raison de changer d'emploi parce
que quand bien même il soit élu
président de la république je crois je
crois qu'à la limite il est plus
nécessaire là où il est que là où il
semble vouloir être mon avis c'est un
gag mais un garde de prendre une espèce
de d'ampleur encore une fois je parlais
de chaplin par exemple pardon de
d'aller chercher de battre le rappel de
grands anciens
j'en parle à un moment de chaplin parce
que je rencontre sa fille pendant
pendant le monde est une erreur et c est
que j'ai parlé de chaplin avec victoria
chaplin plusieurs fois et justement
c'est une chose qui me taraude souvent
c'est assez à quoi ça sert ce qu on fait
quoi et je lui ai demandé si son père à
l'époque où elle l'a connu il était déjà
très très âgés et ils avaient toute son
oeuvre accomplie
l'auteur des temps modernes du dictateur
dictateur
qui a écrit donc des oeuvres à la fois
comiques mais qui disent énormément de
choses sur la société n'avait pas un
sentiment d'échec parce que quoi temps
modernes sa part a changé grand-chose la
condition ouvrière et puis le dictateur
bah quoi ces jours ci en france en 1981
j'ai des amis juifs qui se retrouvent
avec des croix gammées sur leurs murs et
des coups de téléphone anonymes la nuit
en france
aujourd'hui le nazisme revient on croit
rêver mais c'est vrai alors bon faut
être modeste
il faut que nous soyons modestes nous
les clowns comme vous appelle avec a
rien de mépris mépris d'ailleurs qui
rejaillit sur ceux qui l'ont pas ce que
je leur renvoie je me voir je crois
qu'il a dépassé ce stade du clown le
croate lui ce qui compte en tout cas
même coluche lui même variante quand il
dit je pourrais je pourrais dire que
giscard a été élu contre un clown y est
d'une certaine manière assez masochiste
pas c'est pourquoi c'est alors un claude
seiler vous voulez être reconnus sévère
vous savez que à la sortie d'un
spectacle vous avez fait un travail vous
avez accompli un parcours et vous
écrivez ceci et je crois que cela répond
très bien ce que vous pensez à
l'intérieur de votre tête l'une des
âneries que j'entends le plus souvent
après un spectacle venant des
organisateurs directeur de théâtre
maison de la culture etc qui montre
engagée c'est comment avez vous trouvé
le public on ne vous demande jamais si
on vous avez si vous avez bien payé 6
pouces la marche et si vous êtes
pourtant ses deux res
oui c'est vrai comme ça on me dit
beaucoup de bêtises
enfin du côté des des gens des
directeurs d
des organisateurs effectivement
j'entends beaucoup de choses qui
m'agacent il pourrait faire l'économie
de certains commentaires et surtout il
me parle rarement de ce que je viens de
faire me parle toujours d'autres choses
et je sais pas mais chaque soir c'est
une aventure différente et on a envie
qu'on vous en parle un petit peu
tu peux un jukebox je risque ma peau et
artistiques en tous cas chaque soir et
on a l'impression que arrivé à un
certain degré de notoriété justement
c'est le côté bon bah manquerait plus
qu'ils soient pas drôle il manquerait
plus qu'ils fassent pas de monde
bah c'est normal quoi normal tout est
normal bah non pas si vous pensez que
demain tout peut flancher vous demain
vous pouvez être un inconnu vous y
pensez aubin rien n'est gagné on en a vu
d'autres jeux
très franchement ça ne me vante pas ça
c'est pas ça qui me préoccupe ces temps
ci j'ai des préoccupations beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus altruiste femmes en
général quand puisqu'on est injustement
dans dans les dents les acteurs et la
politique quand je vois qu'on qu'on élit
on a le reagan ancien acteur mauvais
acteur à la présence des etats-unis à
l'âge qu'il a 70 ans quand on sait ce
que c'est qu'un mauvais acteur quand on
lui donne sa chance sur le tard on a un
peu peur moi je commence à creuser dans
mon jardin parce que je pense qu'il a à
nous faire parce qu'il va vouloir
laisser un nom comprendre mais alors là
par contre très très peur sur un acteur
la très peur vous avez compris guy bedos
est depuis longtemps que dire je écrire
jeu au delà des apparences narcissique
nombril est ce que c'est aussi dire et
écrire nous donc vous pensez représenter
les autres pas représenté à ce point là
parce que c'est très prétentieux mais
j'ai la parole et g
j'ai l'outil jaloux ticket qui est la
parole l'écriture etc et je croise
beaucoup de gens je suis sur le terrain
je vois des milliers et des milliers de
gens dans les spectacles je fais est bon
et ces gens là me parle l'écrivaine et
ils n'ont pas les moyens n'ont pas le
droit de s'exprimer ils sont témoins
atterré quelquefois parlera par part des
choses que je dis pas ce qu'ils n'ont
ils n'imaginent même pas vous avez bon
on est dans un régime dit libéral terrae
et on nous effraie avec ce qui se passe
dans d'autres pays mais dans la
hiérarchie quotidienne mais un exemple
au hasard cette maison-là ici là la
radio la télévision
il ya des gens qui ont la trouille pour
leur place ils ont peur de perdre leur
place ils peuvent pas ouvrir leur gueule
comme on dit ils peuvent pas ils n'ont
pas le droit
alors ils sont ils sont sans fil bien
que quelqu'un prenne la parole
vous êtes celui là leur ambassadeur j'ai
encore une fois je suis pas assez vous
tenez pour nommer leur nom mais je me
prends pas non plus pour le christ a
pour sa simple e mans je suis un un des
types qui peut dire certaines choses
et à qui on le pardonne rap parce que
c'est sa fonction je parlais guy bedos
d'apparence nombril est ce que et je
rejoins un autre texte de la pièce vous
d'ailleurs le narcissisme qu'on m'a
souvent à juste titre reprochés dont
même mes proches
s'amuse quelquefois sans se gêner et
fortement atténués par sept autres tares
dont je suis au moins aussi gravement
atteints la lucidité c'est pas mal ça
d'un côté le narcissisme de l'autre la
lucidité offert un joli parcours avec sa
nef de pas être du tout narcissique
quand on fait le métier que je fais ça
serait une faute professionnelle rouges
entrent en scène et où j'ai la
prétention de tenir assis devant moi
leur parlant un millier de gens et ça
pendant deux heures et demie les deux
fois sans entracte
si si vraiment j'étais d'une modestie et
de violette
je crois que je ferai un très très
mauvais spectacle
et puis il ya le mot qui vous fait peur
et dont vous parlez à différentes
reprises c'est le mot guerre alors la
guerre je croyais que j'en rajoutais un
peu bon de faire peur dans mon petit
cahier mais depuis 33 jours tout le
monde en parle
rien qu'à la télévision et dans les rues
dans des répertoires différents
le pape giscard d'estaing et raymond
devos alors ils vous font rire tous les
trois aller au bout de la situation
parce que j'ai dit j'ai dit l'un chacun
plaide pour sa boutique cité mais lundi
jeu pourquoi
giscard j'ai oublié enfin en tout cas ça
finit par devos qui disait il faut rire
et moi je rajoute ils me font rire tous
les trois oui effectivement
il vaut mieux en rire non comme dit
l'autre je me dépêche de rire de tout de
peur d'être obligé d'en pleurer un
vraiment cette phrase là on devrait
écrire un peu partout sur les murs c'est
vrai que c'est à pleurer en ce moment
yahia il ya une absence de crédibilité
de la part des gens responsables on a
l'impression que le monde est
complètement déboussolé et nous les
artistes on essaie qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire d'autre
on entend le miroir on nous donne mon de
blizzard alors on parle de ce monde là
comment font par exemple certains
auteurs à l'ancienne des auteurs dits de
boulevard de deux comiques sage aussi
peu si on veut dire pour moi vraiment je
ne sais pas à qui ils s'adressent de
quoi il parle
ouais mais guy bedos vous êtes aussi un
peu responsables à ce moment vous parle
et qui est comme une apocalypse pour
demain vous donner un enfant pour lui
d'ailleurs que vous avez écrit même eu
également pour lui
oui oui je lui demande pardon au début
au début je demande pardon de le mettre
au monde
c'est vrai que de toute façon je trouve
scandaleux et
que qu'à la mort naturelle qui de toute
façon nous guette et qui nous rend tous
les mouvements
il ya une expression de lure cohen que
j'aime beaucoup la tendresse de pitié je
l'est aussi ça pour les gens quels
qu'ils soient
surprenant mais au fond de moi je lai
c'est vrai que ça finit mal cette
histoire là pour tout le monde
il faut pas trop se le dire parce que
sinon on va devenir ennuyeux mais mais
c'est émouvant ces gens qui s'agitent
qui se passionnent et ça et puis qui
meurt à la fin je trouve que c'est cette
dérisoire de toute façon c'est le
parcours complet oui alors il ya déjà ça
que des gens soi disant responsables
encore une fois tous ces vieillards qui
soit au kremlin à la maison blanche ou à
l'élysée enfin bon on peut pas dire
qu'il soit complètement vieux celui
qu'on a le même âge est un peu plus
jeune d'aspect en tout cas mais enfin à
quoi il pense parce que j'ai pas j'ai
pas peut-être qu'effectivement ils nous
prennent pour des rigolos mais mais nous
s'ils savaient pourquoi on les prend 2
de jouer à la guéguerre comme ça parce
que le dialogue dit internationale le
téléphone rouge
mais c'est un c'est un téléphone qui
sert à des débiles mentaux parce que
vraiment c'est que tu aimais mais même
ici lemay fusée mais mais mais on est
dans une cour de récréation des enfants
attardés ou est ce qu'on va chercher ces
gens là je vous envoie mes missiles je
vous donne mon nucléaire oui mais j'ai
pas que j'ai pu qui me disait que qui
paraît que
les américains ont vendu aux russes des
pièces qui sont nécessaires aux missiles
qui sont bon braquet sur l'amérique
c'est l'aller-retour paraguay c'est
alfred jarry là c'est la folie furieuse
père s'en fout ils sont tous fous
enfin guy bedos je comprends très bien
votre parcours par rapport à certaines
phrases comme celle ci et qui explique
un peu de tout ce que vous avez dit
d'ailleurs depuis 17h je n'arriverai
jamais à me fâcher complètement avec la
vie mais de chamaillant réconciliation
nous n'avons pas fini de nous en faire
voir tous les deux la vie cette folle
dont je suis fou effet fait nouveau ça
c'est très nouveau nom ce ponot su ce
nouveau par rapport à je crois que c'est
totalement idiot guy bedos il faut que
je le dis mais je suis vivant j'ai eu
vraiment plusieurs occasions de ne plus
l'être
non
la vie bah oui et puis pourquoi un
enfant alors que alors que je dis tout
ça ben parce que c'est cette force de
vie absolument absurde aussi qui fait
que bah oui pendant la guerre il y avait
des gens qui pendant la dernière guerre
qui n'était pas nucléaire celle ci il ya
eu paraît-il un taux de
natalité très important c'est c'est
justement ce côté émouvant et d'aider
des gens qui qui ont besoin parce que
oui c'est vrai que c'est cette espèce de
de naturel de naturel d'animalité
d'aider des gens je suis en train de
faire de la réclame pour de vrai parce
que ça y ressemblait versement je trouve
qu'on a le droit de choisir d'avoir ou
ne pas avoir un enfant et même le pop
n'a pas à 100 mais à mon avis je trouve
qu'ils se mêlent d'ailleurs d'un tas de
choses le pop ces temps ci il ya plus
sérieux à faire pour pour ce monsieur
tout à fait superbe avec sa grande robe
blanche mais enfin quand par exemple je
lis alors qu'on est effectivement cette
période là que le pape
se préoccupe de l'adultère qui est
commise quand un homme regarde sa femme
un homme marié regarde sa femme avec
concupiscence dit il je voudrais que
même les catholiques pratiquants là je
vais peut-être un peu être un peu
triviale incluant celles mais je
voudrais qu'on me dise comment faire un
enfant si le truc devient pas un peu dur
pour entrer dans le machin brice que
nous lui avons un bon alors il est fou
cet homme là aussi tout dans le regard
le pape l'ayatollah khomeini même combat
on sait plus ce qu'on entend j'ai plus
loin il ya des gens il ya des milliers
de gens qui sont venus applaudir cet
homme là bon j'ai sûrement heurter des
tas de gens qui nous écoutent qui vous
écoute surtout vous tous les après midi
mais si on peut tout dire c'est bon
c'est vrai que vous êtes à peu près la
seule personne qui me donne la parole
aussi longtemps en direct est-ce que ce
soit la télévision fou ou à la radio
alors 12h10 lundi 21 avril et je
poursuis votre journal en attendant la
bombe
nicolas un an et moi j'ai le trac de
finir ce journal qu'est ce que j'ai
voulu faire
qu'est ce que j'ai voulu prouver je ne
sais pas je ne comprends pas bien moi
même qu'un peu comme un cinéaste fou
j'ai filmé de la vie de l'amour à tort
et à travers
il faut absolument que je passe à
d'autres exercices
et puis il y avait cette petite phrase
mais cahier bleu nicolas tu l'a deviné
c'est au cadeau d'anniversaire
c'est un beau livre pour un enfant ils
sont rares les enfants qui un jour pour
aux antennes avoir d'abord inspiré un
livre à sa de ça je suis sûr je suis sûr
de lui faire un beau cadeau
encore une fois j'espère que ça sera pas
un cadeau posthume mais
mais moi j'aimerais bien avoir eu sa
alors vous verrez que certains vous
diront parce que vous avez quitté les
chemins de la gauche que vous êtes fait
happer par les gens de la droite non les
gens de gauche sont pas si bêtes parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens de gauche qui
me ressemble
la gauche c'est pas la gauche avec un
grand g c'est pas ça ce ça se règle pas
fatalement non dans les états-majors mon
visage et décider une bonne fois pour
toutes que la gauche c'est moi alors
donc personne n'est propriétaire de la
gauche c'est pas parce que je critique
la gauche de la critique depuis la
gauche
je trouve que quand la gauche se met à
ressembler à la droite c'est la droite
dans je craque qui était le précédent
livre j'ai trouvé cette fois je ne sais
plus si elle convient bien aujourd'hui
guy bedos lorsque la farce et la gravité
de la vie sont tricotés ensemble un
point l'endroit un poil inverse j'aime
assez d'un je craque ça va j'ai toutes
mes oeuvres complètes la wii les deux en
tout cas et là vous faites des
croche-pieds c'est pourquoi dira oui
c'est vrai mais j'ai changé s'est passé
pas du tout le sait pas c'est pas là
c'est pas la même période
et effectivement
[Musique]
j'aime mieux par goût co2 puis qu'on
cite les auteurs au début il se trouve
que je dents pendant la lecture du
journal
je lis un gros en gros livre sur camus
c'est aussi ce journal un chant d'amour
à la méditerranée je viens au soleil je
retrouve camus le bonheur le ballon mais
je dis c'est un homme qui avait le goût
du bonheur et le sens du malheur je
connais on en guérit pas guy bedos
bien évidemment vous auriez été content
d'avoir un prix littéraire si c'est pas
par ben demain ce sera demain je vous
rappelle qu'ils font avares et danièle
sallenave ont remporté les prix mais je
connais yves navarre ça mais ça me fait
un plaisir puisqu'il maîtrise un petit
bout j'ai pas lu son livre encore et si
l'on veut vous connaître un peu mieux je
crois qu'on peut le faire en vous
suivant
dans ce livre qui paraît aux éditions
calmann lévy n'attendant la bamboo vous
yen d'une manière complète alors là vous
vous êtes montré je ne crois qu' on ne
peut plus tromper sur votre compte
et lorsqu'on regarde on doit avoir
l'impression non pas que tricher mais
que vous dites une autre vérité
peut-être la vraie c'est le sort de la
vérité d'être vrai merci et guy bedos
[Musique]